a baguette is a shape of a stone you
want to see a baguette Moshe some real
baguettes gonna get this is my hair my
friends are big gets done right
[Applause]
[Music]
visionary an artist I don't really
consider myself a jeweler
I just put things together the way I
like to piece
it's not easy business again to need a
lot of bread ten thousand twenty-five
thousand hundred and ten thousand fifty
thousand seventy thousand two hundred
and fifty thousand sixty thousand
hundred thousand sixty thousand fifty
thousand thirty thousand twenty-five
hundred so the diamond district is a
special place is just that nitty gritty
block you know everyone from all over
the world comes here for diamonds so if
I opened up in Soho I wouldn't get the
same traction that I would hear because
everyone's looking for the same stuff
here so when they stumble across me
we're all happy
the first piece I've ever worked on was
Jewish rosary it had a Jewish star in
the middle and then it dropped down to a
hamsa instead of the mother Mary and
across I was in love with rosaries
growing up I couldn't wear it cuz I was
Jewish
sheikha Lizzy white gold about fifty
carat black diamonds in it and then a
lot of tedious enamel work it's not a
pendant this is an art piece I told you
guys I was an artist you guys keep
asking me about this [ __ ] the point is
to get this stuff off people's necks in
stores
[Music]
Anker was is actually for little yachty
we made this piece that's about 60
carats sailors sink on the back it's
just it's just solid piece it's dope
[Music]
there's a computer that basically like a
3d printer this one way and then there's
another way where it's it's just rubber
molds that make this wax so that it
pours into this rubber piece and then
they cut it down the middle and then
basically pass this inside this is a bus
down
[Music]
yadi I saw your show already come pick
up your piece okay
I'm sick of holding this [ __ ] it's
wasting a lot of space in my place a lot
of Mars Royal Oak Offshore rose gold
it's just sexy so every day bees running
in a shower in it take a bath in it do
everything so when I see a watch yeah I
see you know the architectural part of
it I know exactly where I want the
stones how I want it laid out and that's
it we just build it out takes about two
to three weeks blessing it down when I
bust something down I use going EVs
Goods efg color well a sexy stuff so
what we do is we take the watch apart
take the movement out we drill holes all
in it and a bunch of holes probably
about 2,500 holes and then we put the
stones in it and then we set them what
stones and then it looks like this then
the super star the most requested watch
I get would probably be it just this is
more entry level so it's more you know I
mean a lot of people are going for these
before they step up for these this is a
white go up a date Rolex this one right
here is a plane they just basic model
and they get eventually look like this
so the plane Rolex is it's usually a
stainless steel sometimes it's stainless
steel and go this has the day and the
date and this has to be makes sense just
not much of a difference you know so
this is an Arabic style face so their
actual Arabic numbers this was about
26,000 maybe you've been so it's been
pretty popular this is one of my
favorite pieces in the world so this is
a AP and it's the skeleton stainless
steel skeleton the whole face is the
watch went from 46 thousand to about 176
now and then I'm done bust it down where
I like 110 so this is a Royal Oak
Offshore
and it's just the regular bus now really
popular watch very sexy stainless steel
smooth simple I mean as far as chains
goes these are all my favorite I mean
they're Cubans they never go out of
style
these will forever be popping of the
custom lock this is something we do
that's really sexy now you know we've
got the baguette opener button these are
the prom set Cubans he's a fire
this is a double security lock so what
you do is you pop it open like this you
press over here god forbid anybody tries
to smash your Sophia neck they're not
gonna really get too far without your
head prong-set means instead of drooling
into the actual Cuban link like these we
actually solder more gold that sits on
top of the Cuban and its prongs like
this so you set the stones into the
prongs so it actually comes out of the
Cuban link you can see here at zoom in
this way that this one that way it is
60000 soldered 120
these are just regular Cuban link
bracelets you know you have a rose gold
one the two-tone one which is really
cool I'm good no dressing like that you
want
I mean wetting the jewelry game is
really just when you do a game over with
something like this it's too much but
somebody loves you're gonna propose to
about a hundred people here the advice I
have anyone was buying their first
pieces don't waste your time just come
to me